it's unlikely you see code in black and
white and I mean that literally a
developer uses syntax highlighting to
visually visually differentiate portions
of her code but these signifiers between
different kinds of content aren't
something that we interpret consciously
they're typographic cues that add to the
conventions of the programming language
you the developer are reading and
skimming code and how effectively you're
able to do this is actually be informed
by many of the same principles that
determine how effectively you can read
anything else syntax highlighting is
designed and its success is informed at
least in part by the typography just
like with any other discipline specific
typography there are some details that
are unique to the subject matter but
many are generally applicable as well
and because of this typographic
conventions in syntax highlighting can
teach us about using type in many other
situations designing longer form
articles visual identities user
interface design and other things
entirely when syntax highlighting is
successful we don't stop to appreciate
it and this is a good thing but it's
something like it I'd like us to
dedicate some time to and its time and
attention to today our work uses type
extensively and you probably know more
about how to apply some advanced
typographic features than you realize
directly through your familiarity with
typographic conventions in code syntax
highlighting creates a visual hierarchy
and just as they do in graphic design
just all principles help explain how you
interpret the code you're reading
similarity through color is what we
think of when we think of syntax
highlighting typically the syntax is
categorized for you with different hues
it helps you immediately associate
pieces of code know that they're similar
or dissimilar but this is just one way
how pieces of sin taxes are highlighted
and how typographic principles are used
within code various graphic design have
instructors have reminded me over the
years if it's the same make it the same
and if it's different make it different
color is far from the only method we
have to associate and disassociate
things visually
type style typeface weight and
background color are a few that we see
in our code editors for example you
might use bolding to create sort of a
headline for a class name or you might
use a background color you might have a
background color applied when you type
something incorrectly and this is always
faster than running tests to capture
typos so I guess that's qualifies as a
talk on testing now but syntax
highlighting there isn't a single
correct way to do things there's
conventions and they can be followed
ignored or intentionally broken and I
think comments are one of my favorite
examples of this how their design can
place them anywhere in the hierarchy of
a document or your code editor they can
be subtle encouraging you to focus on
the code or they can be the most
prominent piece of your text editor
demanding to be read here they are side
by side the same piece of CSS but they
have a very different visual hierarchy
continuity and symmetry are some other
principles that apply when we're
thinking about how syntax highlighting
is designed particularly for when we're
writing code aligning a like elements
and other contextual features can help
you keep your place while writing code
one bracket might be highlighted when
you select a different one and so that
you are matched or if you're writing a
white space significant language or
using a white space significant
preprocessor you might have white space
character shown or rules or lines appear
to guide your eye vertically and by
maintaining the same syntax highlighting
theme for an extended period of time you
might actually find it your code easier
to read certainly familiarity influences
our perception of code we become
accustomed to our own theme and settings
when speaking about typefaces themselves
type designers whose an Atletico said
readers read best what they read most
and this has more to do explaining while
black letter and older books look
challenging to read to us today but once
once the norm but on a much smaller
level I think it also is true for code
familiarity influences our perception of
code when it's displayed elsewhere to
consider these two pieces of
documentation both are familiar but for
very different reasons
on a first glance which are you more
likely to trust one common graphic
design tool that is noticeably absent
from this list is sighs sighs can very
clearly establish a visual hierarchy but
and this is something we do in
typography and book typography and on
the web of course through a type scale
but within our code editors most of us
would find it pretty strange if
different pieces of code were different
type sizes monospaced typefaces lose a
lot of their benefit for us if we start
changing the size of things at different
points and this is why I think Santa
exciting is a particularly interesting
to way to look look at some other
advanced typographic features syntax
highlighting cues developers on what
they're about to read without ever
involving type size and your familiarity
with typographic principles within code
means you already know how to
communicate these sorts of things within
other kinds of text as well this is
useful because whatever kind of project
you're working on it involves syntax
highlighting beyond code code doesn't
have an exclusive license on this color
and other forms of visual emphasis have
long been used within written and
typographic communication showing
relationships within writing is relevant
to all kinds of text and a prevalent
form of something you could call syntax
highlighting on the web is linked text
the distinct blue hyperlink signifies
that this text is different from the
rest around it these words are different
it says you can interact with them and
color has long been used to emphasize
content and this is a reproduction of an
earhart rat-boy page from the 15th
century where color is used in line for
emphasis what about the beginning and
the end of a sentence period or other
punctuation hasn't always been used to
show this even our idea of the paragraph
wasn't always around the idea of using
space to separate ideas visually jumping
way way ahead even the idea of a type
family that can work in tandem is still
relatively new this is the typeface
univera designed by adrian frutiger a
multi-axis typeface system with
different styles for weights and widths
and it's design is inspired by the
periodic table which includes how it's
presented to other designers type
designer Peter belak said thanks to
fruit ogre it is now common practice to
produce a dozen or more Styles when
working on a new type family and you can
see that in his own typeface Greta this
is just Greta San
there's also a serif and a monospaced
version so this is something this is a
way of working for type designers now
but that's even true for someone who's
much much newer to type design like me
I'm working with the application super
polite or here and I've designed three
master styles and I can interpolate and
generate the other ideas the other
potential styles in between this kind of
power is actually moving even closer to
designers working on the web with
variable fonts which I'm not going to
really cover in this talk but it means
that the tools we have around us to
distinguish content for readers will
continue to be in transition in addition
to a variety of styles many
comprehensive contemporary typefaces
also include advanced typographic
features that allow us to suggest
different kinds of content or make
things more subtle for our readers in
specific situations these advanced
typographic features have been included
and improved within fonts for many years
and are now viable to use on the web
they're called open type features and
just as we differentiate content using
bold italic anchors and other visual
cues we can signify different kinds of
content using these advanced typographic
features to our readers using CSS so one
you might already be familiar with is
ligatures which in opentype is also
abbreviated to lyga and you might think
of ligatures as a beautiful way to
connect two letters and that's true but
often the real goal is to resolve a
spacing issue within the typeface here
the F and the dot of the IR are too
close together especially when used as
small sizes and a ligature can be a
functional and beautiful way to resolve
that spacing issue but as type designer
James T Edmondson has said sometimes you
need a ligature and sometimes you need
an F that just can just chill the F out
in his thesis typeface Kovach you can
see here in the regular version that
there are some collisions happening
ended the italics and one way to resolve
these would be a traditional more
traditional idea of a ligature where
these things connect but he actually oh
here you go so that's highlighted and
but he actually designed the ligatures
and the regular version so the flag of
the F and the dot of the iron moved
closer or further apart and the F and
the L don't collide anymore and then in
the italic version which is more
influenced by brush lettering he did a
more traditional literature where those
things
act so these spacing issues can be
solved through the open type ligatures
feature in a variety of different ways
in a typeface and you can enable this in
the fonts you're already using in your
CSS using the font variant ligatures
property and setting it to common
ligatures but this is really the best
case scenario CSS font variant ligatures
is a lower level property you can think
of it kind of like margin bottom where
we only set one direction of the margin
at once and then the higher level
version of that is margin where we can
set all four directions at once the
higher level property for font variant
ligatures is font feature settings and
this lets us set multiple open type
features at once so that's where that
lyga abbreviation comes into play so
here we're saying font feature settings
will use ligatures but that actually the
problem with this even though it has
better browser support as it breaks the
Cascade if I later want to set a
headline and define different open type
features I'm going to have to read
Eclair everything I've set on the body
which is really inconvenient but as
Rachel said like five minutes ago
anything new in CSS you can use feature
queries to detect support so we already
had a really nice setup for future
queries in the last talk but I'm
actually using supports not here so this
is sort of an inversion of those feature
queries if font variant ligatures aren't
supported then we'll use font feature
settings otherwise we can use font
variant ligatures now this is kind of
confusing and we're only on the first
open type features so I can understand
if you're saying I'm not going to do all
that just to get ligatures fair enough I
put together a little library for you
called utility open type which takes all
these advanced typographic features I'm
going to be talking about and assigns
them to those single to a single class
name those four-letter opentype feature
abbreviations so you can install it
through NPM link to the CSS file
whatever build process you're using and
then you'll have easy access to these
features without having to write those
feature queries so to look at another
application of that ligatures should
really be on by default in the browser
but one that won't be is discretionary
ligature
they're ligatures that are applied at
your discretion here in this typeface
clinics lab there's an ST and a th
ligature which you probably wouldn't
want on through the entirety of the body
copy in your text but you might want it
in a beautiful headline setting so you
could use font variant ligatures and
instead of common ligatures you could
say discretionary ligatures or for
better browser support you could write
that kind of complicated supports query
or at least hard to remember or you can
use my utility opentype library if you
want and a pro I the d-league class name
and then you'll have discretionary
ligatures in your headlines or wherever
you choose to apply them another really
interesting feature is contextual
alternates this is a lavanderia typeface
available through the lost type co-op
it's a a lettering typeface or a
typeface inspired by lettering so there
are features included that make it more
make it feel more like true lettering
done by hand and not a font to take
advantage of these features they'll
become if you take advantage of these
features that the typeface will be more
script like in this case in a at the end
of a word or phrase can get a flourish
and there's many other features like
that another one of my favorites is in
this typeface enemy by Shivan alla para
Mel it's supposed to it's a stencil
typeface but when you zoom in and look
closer you can see that the O's and the
case and the ease aren't actually the
same there's been different versions of
the glyph designs so when they sit
alongside each other it feels more like
an organic stencil and less like a
repeating font so you can use this in
your CSS with font variant ligatures
contextual or the C alt class in my
library now we're halfway through the
second talk today and no one's talked
about emoji yet so I'm happy to be the
first person to mention emojis at this
conference this is a emoji icon set
thing I designed for sad magazine and
magazine in Vancouver this is for their
secrets themed issue so this is what the
Apple emojis like look like there's no
contextual
alternates feature in this icon set or
this emoji typeface I designed for this
magazine it's supposed to look kind of
sketchy and hand-drawn so there's
actually variations of each one of the
glyphs so when you type them in a row
they swap out and make it feel more like
it was drawn by hand and it's less like
a font and the reason I made it a font
instead of just a series of images was
because it was for this secrets themed
issue and it let the designers of the
magazine Pam Ernest the art director i
worked with used use it and encode
secret messages with it without having
to do that manually so it was used on
things like the social media campaign
and I wasn't going to put this example
in but then I was like all right
developers like stickers so there's it's
on stickers postcards and then people
can go to the website and decode those
secret messages before you ask yes I am
currently available for cryptography
work a more practical example of this
idea was done earlier this year by kimya
Gandhi she wrote a really great article
for alphabet org a blog I highly
recommend you check out this is a Devon
Gary typeface she did with many
contextual alternates the challenges of
doing this in a different in this
language aren't one that I'm personally
familiar with but I'm excited about
other designers type designers linguists
what linguists web developers talking
about what it means to bring those
things to the web the language specific
considerations that are available in
tight face is very but there are
features that help with that sort of
thing for example in Dutch the IJ can be
treated as one glyph instead of two so
that this typeface by the type foundry
underwear has a variation for that
sometimes you also get to work with
people who are experts in their field so
I got to work with Americo takagi for a
project for Google Fonts early access
Japanese typefaces and the specimens we
design she really coached me through
what it meant to deal with some Japanese
typography specific issues and you're
particularly lucky here in Singapore
because there's a really great series
called letter love or
by relay room there was an event last
night talk about designing bilingual
multilingual typefaces and if you're
interested in typography I highly
recommend you go check out this event
series it runs every quarter and what
another feature I wanted to talk about
is stylistic alternate so this one is
abbreviated as salt this is the same
typeface lavanderia that we were looking
at in one of the other examples and so
is this by using some different
stylistic alternates you can get a
pretty different feeling from the
typeface and this might be an
interesting way if you're already using
a set of typefaces for a company you're
working for or something like that where
it might actually be more versatile than
you realized sometimes there's just a
few key glyphs in a typeface that really
define its character and by having those
swapped out you can get a different
feeling and I worked on the web based
type tester for the lost type co-op a
couple years ago where we tried to
highlight these features in line for
people so as you're trying things out on
the website as they're trying out the
typefaces those features are all
highlighted for you and this is where
the font feature settings property comes
into play a bit more here we're setting
contextual alternates and stylistic
alternates so this is an idea of
chaining together multiple open type
features case sensitive forms are
another category abbreviated as case
it's particularly I think it's becoming
more and more applicable because we keep
using glyphs in ways that maybe they
weren't used that way before so the at
symbol is one of those if you're setting
handles and usernames with an at and you
set it in all caps now that at symbol
kind of looks too small or like it's
sitting too low compared to the all caps
letters so there are open type features
and some typefaces that will correct
that issue so you have a version that's
specifically for sitting alongside the
the all caps settings and you can use
that with case an extension of that is
small capitals small capitals are
specifically designed to sit along the
lower case letters and these can sort of
highlight things for our readers like
acronyms within a paragraph of text if
you have an all-caps word in the middle
of
in the middle of a paragraph sometimes
it might draw a reader's attention away
when we don't want to do that so small
caps are designed specifically to sit
alongside the lowercase letters they can
still show someone that something is an
acronym but they stick out less in a
paragraph that said no small caps is
better than pho or fake small caps
sometimes people will just scale down
the uppercase letters to the height of
the lowercase letters with the intent of
making them look like small caps which
is sort of in an attempt to mimic book
typography but what this ends up doing
is actually making the all cat the small
caps letters more distracting because
they feel much lighter or they feel
skewed in some way so this is a great
example that shows that by Matthew
butterick from his book practical
typography which I highly recommend you
can see the fake small caps feel much
lighter compared to the capital letters
where the real ones feel like they're
properly designed to sit alongside them
so don't use the old font variant small
caps feature that creates fake small
caps the new property you're looking for
is font variant caps small caps this is
all documented on that utility opens
type site as well so I use that on the
surge pricing page for the acronyms as
an example and you might say that's
pretty annoying to go through and wrap
all those acronyms and span tags but
there's actually a lot of tools that
will do that for you like typographers
in Ruby and for WordPress and a lot of
other things so you can continue writing
your content or letting your clients
write your content and have some of
these spans applied to your markup for
you another category there's other
categories specifically for numbers
since we've mostly been talking about
Latin letters so far old style and
lining numbers lining numbers typically
are the default in sans-serif typefaces
and they are designed to sit alongside
the uppercase letters old style numbers
are designed to sit alongside the
lowercase letters and there they tend to
be the default in serif typefaces a good
way to remember that is the top one here
is verdana and the bottom is Georgia so
in verdana the lining numbers or the
default and in Georgia the old style of
a default
both designed by Matthew Carter but in
that case you know that those features
are potentially available for you in the
typefaces even when the default is
different proportional and tabular
numbers help us align numbers vertically
rather than horizontally so if we're
setting a whole table of information
it's really annoying when things don't
line up properly this makes it difficult
for our readers to scan for information
tabular numbers are essentially
monospaced numbers that are designed to
fit in with your typeface so I've see
some people sometimes switch to just a
monospaced font for their tables but
this way things are preserved
horizontally and vertically and if
you're already loading in a web phone
with tabular numbers you might as well
use them it also applies in animation
and user interface design when the
frames are stacked rather than having
the numbers jump around they can all
stay in place this was really bugging me
on the plane if you're on the plane next
to me I guess you can have the window
seat apparently I'm going to be thinking
about proportional versus tabular
numbers here's a proper execution of it
at a different airport where things are
lined up so you can use that with font
variant numeric tabular numbs and it's
important to remember not all typefaces
have all these features you want to
choose a typeface that has the feature
load the web font and then enable the
features typefaces are different this is
morriston by design by Riley cran I've
set the schedule here in this typeface
and I can switch to the tabular numbers
but if I switch to this typeface sq fina
also designed by Riley cran that option
isn't available that's really because
this is a ridiculous way to set this
table this is a typeface intended for
large display setting so it looks
beautiful like this but I wouldn't want
to set a whole spreadsheet in that
typeface so open type features can
actually be a really good way to help
you figure out what your typeface is
good for when you're evaluating k faces
I know that can be a challenging task
sometimes but these features show you
that oh this is good for setting large
tables of information or this has a
bunch of swashes which means it's
probably more for display settings
if you're using a web font service you
just have to make sure that you are
including these features when you're
loading your web fonts or if your self
hosting web fonts just don't sub set
them out there tends to be documentation
for all of this based on whatever web
font service you're using and it it's
usually a simple if ticking one box but
it differs slightly between each one but
i'll link to those pages on on my
website and then lastly you want to
enable the tabular numbers in your CSS
so again you can use this library if you
want which means then you would just
have to apply the teen um class to your
table and then the small caps class to
the abbreviation here this is all
documented with lots lots of examples on
the site but I think it's more important
it was more important to go through some
examples of how this worked within
typefaces rather than get too deep into
the specifics of the CSS since it's
really just the names of the features
what's more interesting is how these
what features these fonts actually have
developers have frequently demystified
their craft for me including some of the
incredible people you're going to see
speaking here later throughout the day
including some people who helped make
font face of reality and someone who
wrote an amazing syntax highlighting
library so I appreciate you having me
here to geek out about some specific
type of graphic details with you I hope
you can see that typography can be just
demystified to yes you need to develop
an your eye and that takes time but you
can also research and get excited about
the advanced typographic features
already included within the fonts to
help you you also know more about
typography than you give yourself credit
for directly through your familiarity
with principles in syntax highlighting
these typographic conventions in code
and because of this when you design for
readers i'm sure you'll syntax highlight
everything thanks
I'm sure hello thank you so much Kenneth
I think that's a very insightful
information on typefaces and I have like
a little bit of slight envy looking at
your slight designs so is there anyone
who's interested in we're going to take
a few questions so any of you has
questions for Kenneth please raise up
your hand cell will give you the Mike
any questions come on questions anyone
ok i'm going to ask your questions I'm
curious about as someone who's
interested in typography but I only know
one source which is google web fun I was
wondering where do you get like your
resources when it comes to web points
other than google web fun and yeah you
get your inspiration um I I work with
the last type co-op a lot and we have a
lot of typefaces that you should check
out so that's lost type calm and tebow
tech i mentioned peterby lacks typeface
Greta sends they have an amazing catalog
webtype is one but I think the best
advice i really could offer you is to
check out that letter love series that's
based here in singapore it's run by an
amazing type designer who studied in the
netherlands and came back to singapore
and puts on these great events so if
you're if you're interested in type you
should check that out and you'll find
people recommending you a lot of new
things there as well ok thank you any
questions from the audience um hi
actually have a question about the OTF
font format because a lot of the things
that you talked about like ligatures and
swatches are part of the OTF font so how
is browser support for this because
normally when I declare font faces you
have like all the fall backs you have
your right off to Worf's so I is it how
safe is it is it too just grab declare
an OTF browser support is great actually
um that you brought up an important
point these are called open type
features but they're not exclusive to
the opentype font format wafaa and waft
to both include open type features and
since Safari 10 came out all the major
browsers support all the font feature or
the majority of the font feature
settings certainly for Latin based
languages it gets a bit different for
other languages but you can also check
out state of webtype com which is like
the can I use for these features
basically but yeah you don't need to use
opentype font formats this will all work
with woof woof to as well thanks great
questions the audience green um well if
you want to talk type Oh find me oh it's
so yeah one last one yeah sure hi um
first thank you so much I'm in second uh
this is really cool just because I
didn't know about open type features so
the question I had was I'm one of the
first examples you had and you said that
you can set font variant ligatures but
then the higher class way was the
feature settings and then you went into
about support like support I'm and I
think I missed the part where you were
explaining why this is important or else
what would blow up if I don't do it okay
um it's not really the browser support
for font feature settings is very good
and if you just want to use font feature
settings that's totally fine and that
will probably work for most cases if you
are using a lot of open type features in
different ways those things won't
cascade down the document so if you set
certain open type features on the body
you're going to have to read Eclair all
of those on the heading so in the case
of me writing a library to help people
with that I needed to avoid that issue
but in most situations you can just use
font feature settings and no
we'll have good browser support hey
thanks